[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello
[Music]
are we live
[Music]
this game's tripping me out already dude
hello i guess
i i guess
i don't know but hi
is that how we're gonna be today okay
i see hello esther
i bibs
[Music]
hold on
did i do everything i need to do before
we start i think i did
[Music]
hello hello
welcome everybody
imagine not picking bandit i'm not
picking bandit
absolutely not
[Music]
no all right maybe though you said
bandits good in dark souls 1.
[Music]
i like the music
[Music]
i am excellent how are you guys today
imagine picking anything other than
master key
hmm
i'll pick whatever you guys want
i don't care
[Music]
peep the name though it's rick
rick yet
[Music]
again you prefer dark souls 1 or dark
souls 3 dark souls 3 is my favorite
souls game ever even above elden ring um
probably because it was my first
so that's that's probably a big reason
[Music]
oh it comes with the master key what if
i picked bandit and the master key
do i get two master keys
let me see what we're doing so
i would i had so much fun doing the
completionist run of elden ring
that i thought we should do it for all
the games
so i would like to go in order
you know
and you're probably already thinking
you need to do demon souls
first jake that's the first one and i'm
like you're right
i don't have a ps5 i don't have a ps3
absolutely no idea how i could play that
game so
not an option
so for now
we're new dark souls
dark souls 2
that's right
we'll play dark souls 2 completionist
runs through all of them
so we do dark souls 1 dark souls 2
bloodborne i'll get a ps4 or something
i'll figure it out
uh
[Music]
we'll be in the next one dark souls 3
sakiro
yes
so the only reason i'm not continuing
sekiro
is because i wanted to go in order
as much as we can
dark souls 1 is objectively the correct
answer though
i'm aware of that metal thank you
[Music]
why is dark souls so good and we're
going to find out that's what we're
doing
what class should i pick though let me
get my controller
[Music]
warrior knight what is the difference
here
[Music]
some armor
armor
wanderer oh i like wanderer thief
bandit
hunter
sorcerer
pyromancer
cleric deprived
what the heck is coming up on my screen
right now hold on chief hold on people
music gone
what about skiro i said securo
demon souls and bloodborne are
impossible
no
[Music]
bandit or you're lame
deprived
yo what's up kyle what's up kyle
you always go at night
hmm
you have to pick deprived
what's deprived oh i see
is that just a bush
no there's okay i thought
down low there it was just bush
yeah this is the remastered one and
considering this looks remastered i'm a
little concerned but
we'll see dude
we'll see
yes we will continue sakiro when we get
to it yes
absolutely
oh you can't touch him because i yeah
yeah ps5 yeah yeah
it has the best stats
i mean we can go with deprived that's
fine
rick and start low i don't care
um
is master key the right thing to pick
here
i'm gonna need your guys's help through
this whole thing just saying like i
don't really remember this game very
well
[Music]
i'm good kyle how are you man
[Music]
i feel like you guys are [ __ ] with me
on uh
on the deprived class but that's okay
[Music]
you know the last couple of streams we
have not had bots so
let's not jinx it though all right i'm
picking master key
[Music]
hmm
top heavy large very slim
average
that's fine
i don't really care about all this no i
want the shaved head i want the whole
shebang
[Music]
am i on accept
why can't i accept
hello do i have to pick hair
what the [ __ ]
oh i do
weird
i don't have any hair all right
[Music]
i'm sure i'll get two shot and undead
burg absolutely
don't pick deprived you're gonna have an
elden ring bandit moment are you serious
uh-oh okay i won't
[Music]
should i just pick like a knight
[Music]
is that like the best one
[Music]
cleric
is claire good what is this
thief by the way
thief's dexterity is insane
this folsom
the night fat rolls i don't like that
night
[Music]
this doesn't look that bad
uh you guys are saying deprived like
that's fine we can figure it out we're
not like bad at the game right
all right you guys ready
let's do it
[Music]
screw it dude
a story i can actually understand a land
of grey cracks
arch trees
and everlasting dragon do you guys
understand what's going on in elden ring
at all
but then there was fire
and with fire
came disparity
this character's name is rick anthony
yes
life
and death
and of course
light
you think so
yeah i think my answer is i sort of do
but i'm not confident in anything you
know
yeah i don't think you can say yes
outright to understanding elden
that doesn't mean anything though
is
ew he looks scary
the witch of izalith
and her daughters of chaos
rick has no first name
and his faithful nights
besides rick
yeah i feel like we'll know a lot more
when dlc releases for elder ring they
challenge the dragons
hey dragons again
[Music]
it's godfrey guys
fighting place to do sex
[Music]
this story is so good though
[Applause]
[Music]
thus began
the age of fire do you watch anime i
watched some i haven't watched any anime
in a long time
but soon the flames will fade
and only dark will remain do you guys
think elden ring is connected to the
rest of the games
even now like in some ways
but only endless nights i haven't played
this game in like three years
and amongst the living are seen
carriers
of the accursed not connected
not really
why does it look so scuffed on the
screen
go for the black leather armor you see
all the pixels armor in the series emo
ooh garba garma thank you for the five
dollars
black leather armor huh okay where's
that i'll get it just because you said
so
not connected lore was
okay yes indeed
the dark side thematic sense but no way
the same story or universe okay
i think it's possible
and in this land
the undead are corralled and led to the
elden ring is rick's fever dream
thank you again garma i appreciate you
man thank you where they are locked away
to await the end of the world
you explain the scale of having the dark
soul gale had the dark soul as
concentrated as it ever
was since it found and he was really
strong
the scale of having the dark soul
hmm
that's a hard question
i don't i don't know the scale holy [ __ ]
rick looks terrible
oh my god
and hard this thou fight tarnished
warrior
i played way too much elden ring i need
to i'm excited to play something else
my god
okay well the frames are really good
right now
dungeon silky excellent
yeah i look like beef jerky bro
i wouldn't eat it
yo what up cup
you having a bad day
oh my god that guy's having a bad day
hello
is that the asylum demon
nah that's a different one
we got backstabs
oops
this sword sucks
you look like bacon your mom looks like
bacon
and i like bacon
i just press y by the way to go up the
ladder just saying this this is gonna be
tough
it's gonna be [ __ ] weird
wait let me move the chat a little bit
old
hold
let's move that down
smidge
because the ui is a bit different here
okay
that should be better
light the bonfire baby
boom
[Music]
a boom
that's the stray demon okay
what's the
difference you can't jump
holy [ __ ] you actually can't
yeah why is the ui so big it actually is
oh [ __ ]
yo what up what up beefcake
yeah that's not happening i'm out of
here
that's not happening guys
i press y again this guy this is going
to be a struggle guys
it really is
look at the arrow move to try and hit me
look at that movement
what's that move what's that movie
called where the bullets
like
uh
curve
oh [ __ ]
what's this oh i got my club
excellent
excellent
i'm gonna went for it it's possible the
different outer gods manifest different
worlds dark souls could be a similar
universe to elden ring
see i agree
what's in here
how do i use the ui okay i'm figuring it
out i'm figuring it out all right
okay i only have to press y
to change the two hand i like that
i like that you could have done it
i'm not as big of a gamer as you okay
all right
all right i wonder if this game's going
to be stupid easy
not that i'm worried about that
i get do you guys think elden ring was
easy
compared to the other ones
sakura was still hard as balls
speaking of balls
hey yo what up bro
how we doing oh you
you know hollow
no thank goodness
i'm done for it i'm afraid yeah the ui
is really showing its age here then i
lose my sanity i wish to ask something
of you
you and i we're both undead
hear me out will you
what if i just say no
yes i see
perhaps i was too hopeful
please leave me be
i have not longed to live
and i may harm you after death
now
harm me
nerd
why
because i allow it
that's why
very nice very nice what the heck is
this oh that's the ball
rip oscar
how dare i how dare how dare you
that is a very different backstab sound
than i'm used to
interesting
how could you do that to her boy listen
he dies anyway
spoilers he dies anyway all right
oh that arrow still hit me bro
just how is this remastered like this
looks exactly like the original dark
souls what's remastered about the
graphics
i don't see an improvement
i'm dead
you can't move while drinking estes
remember when i said the game's gonna be
easy
i'm struggling
there we go
i am hollow
don't you dare go hollow chat
don't you [ __ ] dare
yeah my ass looks good
am i wearing fia's panties like [ __ ]
what up bro
i can't move dog i
i couldn't move
i couldn't see or move bro
i don't even know what happened
i don't want to talk about it
i i thought eldon ring was just as hard
as dark souls 3 but then i entered the
consecrated snow fields in halo tree and
for sure elden ring is harder
i think the late game of elden ring is
extremely difficult anybody else
extremely difficult
late game
okay i can run
son
why did my guy just come what the hell
was that noise
do you hear that
oh
nice
okay we're struggling
where's the music
the music's gone
that's cringe
i tried to jump attack
smack that ass like a drum
there we go
listen listen that that that death
it didn't count
right guys
yeah they cracked up the damage in the
enemies i don't think it's like
an elden ring i don't think the late
game is like
the late game's kind of weird i really
like the bosses though i think i think
most people will agree on that right
like the bosses late game are really
really cool but they just ramped up the
damage and the
the health so hard that it's like what
the [ __ ]
like as soon as you go to the snow
fields
yeah what does only
in the ancient legends it is stated
that one day an undead shall be chosen
to leave the undead asylum in pilgrimage
church a pilgrimage
lordran
bird
that's all i have to say bird
melania is the hardest boss in the souls
series
i think so too
just objectively
i mean i am literally wearing panties
like straight up this is panties
level up and kindle at bonfires
okay
who's this stupid idiot
well what do we have here
it's varying
arrival
let me guess fate of the undead right
yeah where's the moonville first but
there's no salvation here
you'd have done better to rot in the
undead asylum
but too late now i don't understand the
giant bird well since you're here the
bird takes you to lordran there are
actually
two bells of awakening two bells
the other
in the is at the base of blight town
bring them both
and something happened
brilliant right
and something happens
i have a feeling that won't stop you so
off you go it is why you came isn't it
wait isn't this why
hander like near here
we gotta do the rick build again
is it the zyhander like actually near
here
i got three levels what what do i do
what should i do
[Music]
oh wait let me go get the sword and then
i'll know
it is actually near here
i'm not going to blighttown first come
on now come on now
yeah it's in the graveyard yeah yeah
yeah
we gotta go there
isn't it over here
oh my god
the fact i can't jump
strange
yeah it's down here somewhere yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay
soul of the undead
i don't do much damage to those guys
i think i gotta run
or it's a better idea to run
nice
nice you know what i'm noticing and
maybe you guys have noticed this as well
just like walking around in the first
couple of areas
there's no like oh there it is i'm out
oh god
okay wait wait wait wait
what i was going to say have you guys
noticed that there's no like background
music
besides like right here right
let me go get my my runes my souls [ __ ]
there's like no bathroom background
music like as soon as i walk out of
firelink shrine it's just like ambient
noise
i like it
okay
how good is this wait oh god
uh huh
what are the requirements
where do i see the requirement
[Music]
all right we'll figure it out two-hand
runes you say
where are my souls
where'd they go
dog why are they all the way over here
are they just trying to kill me
i'm scared
go to the equipment menu and toggle you
okay
oh my ass
it hurts
the bird look at that
what's the bird's name
yeah he's just doing his job that's true
see there's the background music
isn't that weird
okay so equipment menu
i think is there
no that's not it
browse and use items
so while hander toggle display
24 strength
and 10 decks
the 24 straight
my god
okay okay that's fine
that's fine
we'll get there
snuggly crow
all right we'll get there guys
we will get rick to where he belongs
let's go back to our club though
we'll make do where do we want to go
first
i guess the right way would be this way
yeah to start
i don't think you can two-hand it can
you
not yet anyway
glorious chest ahead
do you mean boobs
nerd
you kind of do a jump attack
my guy likes getting hit do you hear
that
okay
pump a rump
pump a rump
i think there's a lot of sexual
innuendos in the souls games
i don't like this
i'm fine
praise boobs
what are y'all doing
pickle p
see
see
okay we're fine we're fine
what am i hearing
i think i hear the rat that's in there
what's over here
pickle pea
pump a rump
remember alexander wanted to be lubed up
before you hit him
just hit me in the rear with something
nice and big
like come on now
some people pay good money to get hit
how do you know that blue kingdom hmm
are you aware of this
holy
that guy went at me
that's just cringe and dumb
hello
okay good
the graphics were different back then
can you guys believe that like this
looked great in 2011.
what am i hearing
someone's getting [ __ ] all right
okay well you know what i have to do in
this room right like this is just a
thing that you have to do when you see a
room like this you just do this
you know
you're welcome
you're welcome
oh well
rick roll
you're welcome
can you jump over there
wait you can't jump well yeah you can
okay
listen
link heavy breathing
yeah uh
yeah so the graphics don't really look
that good
for the remaster
can we get blue point on this [ __ ]
i want like a demon souls remake version
of dark souls please
isn't this a door i can open with the
key you guys wanted me to use
no
not the right door
a shield
ain't no [ __ ]
already a bonfire nice
that's right
we're no strangers to love
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta make our own background noise
because there's like none
in this game
oh [ __ ]
i forgot okay listen
listen
listen
yeah
i mean you know like el yeah elden ring
of course refined everything about the
souls games
but this is still really good it feels
clean
[Music]
i
just wanna tell you how i'm feeling
trying to make you understand never
gonna give you up never gonna let you
down never gonna turn around and desert
you
it's fine it's fine
okay let's continue let's continue
where am i
i'm lost i'm gonna go this way
mommy oh [ __ ]
nice
nice
no this is the door i can open
your
what is this
it's like uh electrics yep gold pine
resin
that makes my weapon electric
electric avenue
wanna take me higher
okay i don't have to jump
excellent
sir
stop it
kind of hitting everything right now
like
one shot
nice to meet you lost i'm dead
get annihilated kid
you're bad at fortnight
[Applause]
i think that's the worst thing you could
say to any kid right what are you doing
up there
you're bad at your job
hopefully it's not playing fortnite
i'm gonna die i'm dead
okay
oh my god i'm just the best in the game
that's all there is to it
doesn't get better than me boys
watch this
that's how you dodge that
get that load up though bro
[Applause]
never gonna
[Music]
where does this go
hello
mommy
i don't want to go down there
if i remember correctly every boss is
weak against electric except for gwen
that would make sense
havel wait havel's down here
um do i go down there and fight havel
probably not the best idea yet just
saying
don't these explode
nope
guys i remember now havel's down there
okay
i know
perry perry with what your mom
that's the only thing i got right now
okay
i hear [ __ ]
jump
nope
isn't there a boss out here
oh nut sack bro
yep
did you take out the rock of course
dwayne the rock johnson has nothing on
rick
all right do i get this first try guys
first try
first try
you can't slide down ladders okay that
could have been added into the remaster
i feel
i really do
optimal havel
oh here we go
decent damage
not bad
don't really know how that one
worked so i got scared
i got skin
excellent
i can't see dawg
my heart no
get up please
imagine not believing in me
imagine hey guys
imagine
games easy peasy holy [ __ ] that's pretty
though
you telling me the lands between and out
there
huh
any doubters
yeah remastered comes with the dlc so we
have it yeah
i'd say dlc is the best part of like all
these games
you're welcome
praise the sun
no axe
reset no axe body spray
it's locked
ao true
it's him
it's him
you all know what to do
it's him
ah hello
you don't look hollow far from it
i am solaire of astora an adherent i
look hollow as [ __ ]
i am undead i have come to this great
land the birthplace of lord gwyn praise
the son my very
you find that strange we need to praise
the sun emote
no need to hide your reaction for this
playthrough
what is your decision
the way i see it our fates appear to be
intertwined in a land brimming with
hollows could that really be mere chance
so what do you say dude he's jacked one
another on this lonely journey
okay
this pleases me greatly
well then take this
white science soap zone we are amidst
strange beings in a strange land
the flow of time itself is convoluted
with heroes centuries old phasing in and
out
and relations shift and obscure there's
no telling how much longer your world
and mine will remain in contact but use
this
to summon one another as spirits cross
the gaps between the worlds and engage
in jolly cooperation there it is of
course we are not the only ones engaged
in this
but i am a warrior of the sun
spot my summon signature easily by its
brilliant aura
if you miss it you must be blind
jolly cooperation
it really would fit rick's uh rp but
can't do it yet can't do it yet
jolly cooperation
charlie
okay so
am i near a place where i can rest yet
like sheesh dog
okay i think i know where to go i think
i have to go
into that little space in between the
bridge go down under
kick down the ladder and then i can walk
back up okay i know what to do i know
what to do
run
you'll see why
you'll see why
run
get absolutely annihilated dragon
somebody is behind me or above me
this is like warzone audio right now
i'm going this way
this way will be fine i just want to
level
i'm cringing
at myself
can i kick
yep
okay we're fine
[Applause]
three
[Music]
but actually got poison from one hit dog
what the why am i here
oh no
okay
oh no
oh no
all right
a situation
is underway okay
we we have a problem
[Music]
like this is a problem people
oh [ __ ]
this is not how you're supposed to do
this by the way oh god
run run run run run run
no
we'll be safe
we'll be safe
oh my god thank you
did any of you have any doubt that i
would live through that
any doubts any doubters
[Music]
um
[Music]
like come on
that was so easy
[Music]
it's our boy
well you must be a new arrival
if you require smitty then speak to me
should i just like preemptively
upgrade my zyhander because i think i'm
gonna use it the whole game
like it's a pretty damn good weapon
through the entire game right
i'm gonna
i wonder if i could two-hand it now
wait
[Music]
oh i can let's go
let's go
[Music]
now we're strong
i dislike public pooping but i like the
smell advice
nope oh god
it's kind of weird bro
damn
what is that hitbox
got lucky i'll take it
i don't want to talk about it
that hitbox was insane
i need some armor don't i
i really need some armor huh
why did he moan dude that's what i've
been saying
[Music]
okay where do i go oh
[Music]
is that secret secret
squidward
squidward
c guard
oh my god it is
[Music]
can we get some hmms in the chat please
can we get some hmm
[Music]
i should say that these won't budge
no matter how long i wait
and oh
but i waited
so here i sit in quite a pickle i'm
pickle bread
oh he's insane huh
still closed
still closed hmm
this area is pretty i mean for a 2011
remastered game
when did this game get remastered like
what year
[Music]
because
i'm not gonna cap like this game looks
no different from the original
[Music]
hmm he dies in this doesn't he i don't
know i don't think so
what's our damage looking like
156
nice
nice
remasters came up in 2015 no i mean like
when did this game get remastered
oh [ __ ] i'm in trouble huh
okay that's decent damage
okay three hits
we already broke the game
a tit shard
yay
okay for a second i thought that was
queen america and i was gonna have a
freak out okay
the fire keeper soul
guys look it's goats
it's the rolling goats with a lion and a
guy godfrey
america
just saying
what's your weapon art lol
weapon art
lol
bones shard ahead should i go down here
real quick
yes
yes i should
fps increase
well yeah that's good i guess
obviously
i don't think you can call it a remaster
though can you if you just up the fps
because it looks exactly the same
like graphically i suppose
where's melana
hello
hello there that's what i said if we are
not acquainted i am petrus of
thoroughland i don't like this guy
already with us if not i'd prefer to
keep a distance if possible
oh
okay hello there i realized that i have
requested that we retain our distance
but i also want you to know that it is
not meant in ill will here
take this
as a token of peace
no go ahead
it's for you
wow
oh my
oh
i know
how about this i have to await my
companions here anyway
so what if i were to teach you some
miracles you guys wanted me to kill him
please you
yeah
very well
the copper coin thing is stuck on the
screen
no
that is a shame
but each to their own speak to me i like
the way this guy thinks
to each their own
we should tell
so many people
that ah background music
just so many people that exact thing
in the world would be better
do i got any poppy boys i got a lot of
puppy boys
excellent
he's a bad man i don't think so
not yet anyway
[Music]
yeah was that celibace
what the [ __ ] is his haircut
all of us boys had that haircut when we
were 10 just saying
hello
no response she cannot speak
reinforce esther slacks
use fire keepers should i do this
i mean yeah right
i beat the
demon on the bridge
yeah absolutely okay that's what i
thought
okay cool i didn't know if it like did
something weird
wait i can talk
but it said she cannot respond
okay cool cool cool
what's going on down here
[Music]
it's like a golden seed okay okay okay
good good good
we're going to no crown
wow look at the rendering on these
statues guys that looks so good
holy [ __ ]
i mean damn
so much detail it's like i'm playing
tomb raider on my ps1
i don't want to go that way yet do i
remastered yeah
how how was this remastered received by
most
dude that guy was just chilling i am so
sorry
did people like this remaster i didn't
really know either way
you haven't lost your head
more importantly you're free how on
earth
well
i shouldn't cry
no not my first time
it's been a few years though look at me
now
can you believe it
okay
what is it have you
it was really negative don't worry
no intention of escape
it's safe here
can't bear the thought of going hollow
out there
although i must admit
what a weird place to have a blacksmith
i'll show you what may be the best
i see
i i still don't think you can call it a
remaster though right
if all you do is up
upgrade a little bit of stuff
you know
what do you have do you have any armor
come back soon
smithing helps soothe my nuts
don't let me wither away at all
i mean you're the one choosing to do
that sir
that's fine
blighttown became playable
how much did they sell this for
oh that's a big use of the master key
huh
wait i remember a ring that's really
good in this direction
we can't go to blighttown already can we
i mean we can but
forty dollars
whoa scary
i made a mistake
mistakes were made i didn't think he
would get up
all right maybe we don't go that way um
let's go back to the elevator
because we we could beat the gargoyles
right
right guys
we could totally beat the gargoyles
right guys
might be a little difficult but you know
all right
the rings on top of the tower where all
the drakes are that's right
that's what i was going for
didn't uh
didn't get there
my opinion dark souls one is more of an
open world than elden ring
um
i mean
yeah like i just had the choice to go
where i wanted to yeah
i don't know if it's more than elden
ring
damn
i am just bopping these nerds huh
i mean
we got a problem
problem
it's a wizard
oh that sound is scary
[Music]
oh
i remember using that straight sword in
dark souls 3
as taurus
oh my god they hit for a lot it's
probably because i have no [ __ ] armor
and they're buffed
congrats on going back to golf uh how
the practice going for that it's pretty
good like uh
i need to find
a place to play
every day
i haven't found a place yet
i might have to join a club
oh here thinks
that straight sword is the best in dark
souls 3. isn't that the one that uh
scales with um
luck
little trade off there okay we can both
heal up that's fine
fair
isn't golf an expensive sport not
necessarily
like i can go hit balls for
a couple hours for like 10 bucks
i'm so smart that just looked breakable
dude
oh hello who are you
oh
still human are you
then i am in luck
could you help me nah this guy's suss
huh
okay
i didn't want to open that really
thank you
yes sincerely oh the clubs are expensive
i truly appreciate this
and i guarantee a reward
only
later
wait why later
yes very sorry
your reward will have to wait i've just
been freed
allow me some time
okay
uh i'm gonna leave him
his armor is really cool
try and kill him if you can doesn't he
go to the uh
he he goes to the [ __ ] um he'll kill
your fire keeper
kill him for the ring he goes to the
fire link and
he probably shouldn't leave them okay i
won't i will murder him right now
because you're all sane too
you guys are gonna get me killed
what if this is our fate
i'm scared
wow
i don't like this area we are currently
fighting in
holy [ __ ]
decks build
i'm struggling in this corner currently
struggling in the corner currently
i'm the best in the game
nuts
nice
ring of favor and protection
that sounds good
is it good
boosts hp stamina load breaks when
removed
uh yeah that sounds great
okay
nice did i get his armor
rip 100 run yeah we're just gonna play
the game we're gonna do as much as we
can i'm just gonna listen to chat
and that's what i did
how am i making boot sounds with my bare
feet it's kind of weird
you could kill him while he's in
firelink
now he can't help you with the boss
fight
that's okay
go kill havel i don't want to kill havel
yet
oh cutscene
it's the ring of fap
i need to go get the the ring from what
we were just talking about by that
dragon that killed me
[Applause]
three
we need to remember that i have no armor
[Music]
oh god i forgot there's two
[Music]
okay good first try right
holy [ __ ] we're far away
okay
not really we're fine
this is fine
this is fine
oh we're keeping track of my deaths i
see all right all right that's fine
rip all of the background music
you can summon solaire for that fight
where
do i have to use the summon sign
where can i get that armor that uh
garma said earlier
i feel like i need that
i'm doing a thing that might be a
mistake
we'll see how it goes
it's not going well
it's going very poorly right now
cut the tails off yeah i know it's
easier said than done sir
the basement what is the basement
where is that
hey guys should i cut off the tails
what do you think
his tail is a weapon
i rolled the same i did i did do that
this guy's tail's already gone
[Music]
oh god
so they can hit me while i'm down huh
okay
go to the basement for black leather
armor the door on the bridge you tried
to open before meeting solaire
wait how do i get in do i have the
basement key
oh i do have the basement key actually
i do
okay
i'm trying to remember where that was
and how i can get there
i'm remembering
it's coming back to my brain
okay
should i cut the tail
easier than if you locked on
hey guys
guys
guys
guys
what do you think i'm about to say
take take a guess
you don't need armor you have it come on
hey
hey guys
guys
i want the armor okay
guys
dragon no dragon
i just want to get here
excellent
and i don't want to use a summon sign
i'm going to do it myself
nobody's gonna guess
nobody's gonna guess
ugh
[Music]
i was going to tell you all to shut the
[ __ ] up
thank you
shut the [ __ ] up
1k souls that's nothing i'll go beat
havel right now
completely forget what i was doing
just despite you chat
that's it
that's it
that was weird
sounds
we'll do a rick build for all the games
sure
thing is he hits me once it's over i
think
well
told you
i [ __ ] told you
didn't i
oh
i [ __ ] told you
that was a form of abuse
backstabs are easy peasy
you got hit more by this guy than havel
are you trying to become giant dad
absolutely
melano or fia for what
playing this on switch got to the
painted world right there this guy was
like no matter how many backstabs i got
his health wouldn't go down
and it was an actual player that's
definitely a hacker
i can imagine hacking
the uh
the wii
very easy
okay where is this armor at
armor
armor
it's a very long
letter
what boss have you struggled with the
most in the series uh definitely melania
why did they not add the slide mechanic
into the remaster
hello
mommy
mommy
wait why am i here
after the second ambush it's in one of
the little houses that they come out of
oh anything but a dog
you can slide how it wouldn't work
i just tried to do it
i'm scared they're so fast
bruh
how did that not hit
dude
i hit the other one
[Applause]
wow okay
hold down b that's what i was doing it
wasn't working i swear
i swear it wasn't doing it
okay you said second ambush right so
this is the first one
for her
i think
okay
there it is
there it is
i should have been abandoned
i i should have been a bandit
[Music]
where even am i right now oh my god
that was so far
okay
see once we get
armor
it's all gonna unravel
and you guys wanted me to be deprived
huh
just out here with my butt ass naked
butt right in your face
let's see how it is
i see what you guys are into
don't think i don't see it
i forgot to tell you to open that gate
oh yeah
and we'll get there eventually
i'm gonna try and hold b again down the
ladder
i'm a little scared
what's up with the seamless co-op for
elden ring unless this was answered what
do you mean
what about it
okay i'm holding down and now b
i am holding down the b button
the run button
nope
i am moving down and holding b and
nothing is happening
i'm not kidding
i am not kidding
no joke on a smoke
hold b then hold b
what the [ __ ] you mean
hold b then go down
what
what words are coming out of thy mouth
oh kindred
i don't know how to handle the dogs i
ain't gonna count this this is just
terrible
what game
i don't know what gate you're talking
about
are you guys doing more videos i don't
know maybe
how he died in the fire what an idiot
gotta hold b
then go down
not go down and hold b
go up the stairs and open the gate oh i
see what you're saying now so i don't
have to run as far
thank you for trying to make my time
easier thank you
i appreciate it
ah
thank you
thank you
see this this is why i paid chat the big
bucks
sure wish i got a notification when you
go live
you know you can do that
that is a possibility of doing that but
you didn't press notify me
i'm scared
terrified actually
nice
yeah turn that bell on people
you two running wild was hilarious
yeah i had a lot of fun making that
video and i loved playing with metal but
the video didn't do very well so you
know i got the i got the vibe that like
hey
don't make the video anymore and i'm
like okay sorry
that's how youtube works so that's how
being a youtuber works it's like hey a
video didn't do well let's not do that
video again you know
dang it
[Music]
at least now we have the door open
you died any members in the chat that
have our emote
the only member i've seen is esther and
metal
actually
i'm having a bad time right now
excellent excellent
are you kidding
you died
there it is
[Applause]
you guys can have our cool emails too
just saying
oh my god
they respond
of course they did why wouldn't they
respawn jake that's how the game works
it's pretty obvious you dumb forehead
with a cartwheel
[Music]
okay nice
the footsteps are such a odd sound in
this
let's try this again
you can do it jake
i believe in you
fight the gargoyles fight fight the
guard whale
are you gonna like freak out if i don't
[Music]
you gonna freak
another dog
oh thank god i think it's all over
okay in one of these houses you said
this one
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
rick's looking pretty good guys
rick's looking good
god damn
we're gonna have to upgrade our stamina
a bit
or endurance or whatever it's called in
this game
yeah i know you got to slay the
gargoyles
guys
what did i say earlier
oh i have the havel ring
what was my advice to y'all earlier
it
was
the [ __ ] up
right
it's good advice i promise
it's really good advice
you you're gonna love that advice
someday
maybe not right now
okay what do i level now
yes of course i love you but i can tell
people i love to shut the [ __ ] up as
well okay
no in the bottom of my heart when i tell
you to shut the [ __ ] up it's because i
love you and i just want you to be quiet
or i don't want you to tell me what to
do actually that's that's all
endurance or vitality okay let's let's
look up our health a bit since we're
dying and
uh pretty quick pretty quick
pretty quick can you travel between
bonfires is that a thing in this game
or nah
can i fast trample mom
oh you have to be ornstein and smoke to
do that don't you
i kind of like that you can't
is that weird
like right now
i'm sure it's really helpful later but
right now i kind of like that you can't
it's like open more open worldy like
lorenzo said earlier
yeah we gotta earn that right
after getting the lord vessel
[Music]
the body almost dragged me off
i feel like we're doing pretty good
[Applause]
progress is being made
died a few times but you know that is
that's the name of the game
got beautiful music playing in the
background bro
about to hit the bonfire
what happened oh
this guy's too close
i like how it lights up
holy rags
this is solid progress so far
you have to get the magic bull in anor
londo okay
it would just be tedious having to run
back and forth just complete the game
yeah but that's like a part of the game
dawg
you know what you're going for yet i'm
just playing the game that's all
you know
okay let's go beat the gargoyle so uh
whoever you were in chat can
shut the [ __ ] up
this armor looks cool
is this the armor you told me to get
karma
what
nice
metal how many hours do you have in this
game
again
it's my fave it looks really cool i like
it too
kind of look like darth maul
find it yeah
you have over 2 000 hours damn
hot
that's that's just attractive
all right here we go
nice start
excellent
i mean i mean i just panicked man there
ain't nothing else to that that was just
pure panic
that's all that was
oh my god
all right um
i don't have anything to say about that
nice try right guys
nice try
this is a magnificent strategy of
blinging myself off of the roof
what
i don't have stamina
sometimes i blow by this guy and
sometimes he blows me you
know there we go
oh a titty shard nice
oh
as rick says when he gets hit rick's
into uh
what is it called
it's not called bondage
it's a titty shard
bdsm
i want to say i'm trying
okay
just before you all get all your panties
in a tizzy
i'm trying
[Music]
[Music]
holy
[Applause]
[Music]
so
um
you know
i thought it was a better attempt than
the last one
if we're thinking of positives
positives from this
positivity
all right guys it's better than the last
one
i always got to keep thinking of the
positives guys okay yeah stamina is kind
of killing me right now
we'll get it we'll get it we'll get that
grass crush shield
we'll up our stamena next time
like we're gonna be
fine oh
[Music]
yes i love it
yes
i'm doing fine we're fine
the walk of shame
who's shane
nope let's not use that word
[Music]
what is he doing
[Music]
i was gonna walk off the cliff but i
forgot you can't jump and i'm
embarrassed of that too
that's true the only thing that can kill
me is me
it's pretty obvious
it's me
i'm my own weakness
you know i i i care too much
at every job interview ever what's your
weakness
uh i care too much
i guarantee you don't give a [ __ ]
about none of this
see why are they like gang-banging me
now
i still can't believe people completed
the game without taking any damage at
level one yeah that's just stupid i
can't do that
like what the heck is he doing there
okay
[Music]
just punch me in the mouth
when he has a heartburn
first try right guys
that was amazing
god like you could say
god like
there we go
gg easy no retry we're just the best
we are simply just
the best
wow i do like the sky boxes in this game
it's really showing its age though like
graphically for sure
the first bell of awakening huh
one of many
or one of two
hold b first then go down okay i i will
try
[Music]
what does that do what does that open
okay
holding b
so i do a backstep
going down the ladder
y'all can shut up
it doesn't work
doesn't work
okay
holding b
or the run button
going down the ladder
all right doesn't work
oh okay you know what i i'm nipping this
in the bud all right
you told me before i'm over it
okay
on the ladder
be
i'll admit when i'm wrong thank you
greeting
i am oswald of kareem
i was wrong
thank you
should i kill this guy
well
what is it
okay
purchase item purging stone
book of guilty
velka's talisman what is that
uh medium for casting miracles on the
gods i don't really want to do that
request absolution
do i want to do any of this right now
he gets rid of curses okay
[Laughter]
like you guys have no idea how bad i
want to cut his head off right now but
i won't kill him i won't do it
now what look at look at these guys
still trying to come through the door
look at that
look at this
what are you doing
imagine
okay what do we what do we want to do
now
what's the plan
he may seem evil but he's good yeah i
mean he does not seem good at all
okay i mean that was kind of cool right
like that was sick
at least a little attractive right
okay let's go back down down down to the
bottom of the sea
where i'm going to
do what
gangbangs waiting for you
well i dominated that gangbang
that was just
i i did it
ah
[Music]
andre
what's up infamous
okay
i got four
[Music]
murder andre for the crust
no
[Music]
no
get that to 15
get that to 13.
that seems fine
okay
wait kendall
can i kindle while hollow
[Music]
do i want a kindle
no i don't actually
okay
[Music]
i think i can upgrade my sword
[Music]
well hello again
you seem to be doing all right i'm doing
pretty good anything forged absolutely
reinforced weapon
hinder
excellent
i need another tit
shard i'm not killing andre
okay let's see how we do against this
guy now
i just want to say the hitbox here is a
bit redonk
heal up here
nice nice nice
will this give me a titty
kind of looks like a titty getting stuck
on its hand
that hurt
i'm dead
gg no reed
what
okay
what
i
[Music]
what
a rick kebab
oh my god
i'm going to kill this guy
maybe not right now
i'm trying to heal
i'll take it i'll take that
what hit me the tail
save him for later
hmm
we got it we got demon tight knight okay
i don't know what that is but we'll take
it
see you know you just got to give me a
couple chances bruh
like we're good
do i want to be out here
where am i uh oh a tree
uh oh
[Applause]
okay
i've been wrong too
okay
i'm gonna go this way
don't i get the grass crest shield over
here
because we want that don't we
like definitely
it is dark in scowy
thanks nandes i'm glad you like it
broccoli mobs
yeah
broccoli
it's a titty shard lizard
couple of twinkle tits nice
i like twinkle tits
this can't be it
okay okay
we'll take that
twinkle tits absolutely
why am i here
oh god
i am
scared
of these guys
i frames iframes
no
it's the only way i die
no
dang it
[Music]
i've only died by falling
[Music]
huh
why does rick love falling so much
the asylum i know
the one time
it feels like i've only died from
falling
it's very nice out here
very peaceful
okay you guys complained about
fall damage and elden ring like
i felt like a foot there
took a chunk
okay we want to keep going down
okay i got my my rooney boys my souls
not runes
okay
i wanted to fall
i had no stamina
no stamina
hi kyle thanks for being here dude
i keep wanting to jump
this is a problem
not again
i wasn't screaming you were
okay we at least got it
okay let me like this
and i'm gonna kill him
no no i'm gonna i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna be smart
nice
more stamina
is there a chance he drops his uh
zweigender
or not his right-hander is kind of
hallbird
i don't know what's happening either
black knight
i think my dog is barking
she is barking
see why that time
holy [ __ ]
wait really
first try
there's a really low chance but he drops
it
no
best weapon in the game
that is unreal luck right
[Music]
oh
my god
i don't want to talk about it okay
uh
wow okay
well
first order of business what is required
of it
sorry that was gross um
32 strength and 18 dexterity
it's kind of a lot
we will use this at a later date
strength index is what we are going for
people strengthen decks
that is what we are leveling
strength decks and health
we need a lot more decks and i can only
level that once
i might as well get that
okay more strength for now
we'll keep getting more rooney voice
what's over here
holy
i was just mindlessly walking
what about stamina yeah we'll we'll
level all of it okay
i mean that
metal are you giving people your
instagram
i love it
oh elstad thinks maddie's bad huh
it's true
okay i want that ring up there
somebody is sipping in the chat
this is fine we're fine
okay what does this do
boost attack while hp is low okay well
that's cool i'm not gonna use that right
now
how do i get down here
if i die i died
you know it is what it is
where do we go now
what would be the next
place to go
where's our next area
blighttown
oh capra demon
you're right
what up stan
what up stan
or painted
i
don't know what i'm looking at right now
metal it seems like a corpse getting a
bj
okay
okay so we gotta go kill capper demon
yeah
nice
we'll go this way
i'm confused me too
uh
do i have an issue here
crossing this path is this going to be a
problem
i think it is
i'm hitting the paw
nevermind
who said no
because you were wrong
i'm gonna go the other way
i know it'll take a bit longer but i'm
gonna go this way
just annihilated huh
get one tap nerd
i did
i had to write my album favorite album
art for my class and that was it
i like it
actually really good album art
you know that is
great positive outlook on that at least
i didn't die to fall damage
that's what we do here right guys
positivity
nothing but
nothing but positive
positive vibes
out here right
the positive vibes okay i'll stop
i was gonna get a little weird for a
second
sing like one of the boys
get weird trust me it will
let's let it happen naturally
this little natural weirdness did
absolutely annihilated that bush bro
absolutely bonk dawn did
[Music]
reverse halloween do i want to do this i
have a humanity
but i have to bop it don't i
am going to do that right now okay let's
go
you guys don't like rick's moaning i
actually love
it i think it's cute
see how it's getting weird naturally
this is what we're going for
imagine a no bonfire run
pop your hermana tussy okay hold on
humana what
what does that do
all right
where am i trying to go again asylum
demon
or no no no
[Music]
cap or demon
reverse halloween
[Music]
kindle
[Music]
hey i don't look
crazy anymore
[Music]
should i kindle the fire
you get 10 flasks
yeah i want to do that
[Music]
do i have to do this to several uh like
every bonfire
[Music]
i don't think i ever did that in my play
through this game
[Music]
okay let's go kill the capper demon
only the bonfires you rest at and that
you kindled okay thank you
this whole time i've just been trying to
get back to the fire lake
we already talked the
to our boy sigmar
he's waiting for the door to open
have we been going for two hours yeah we
have wow
wow
oh i wanted to ask you guys this do you
guys watch
other youtube live streams
because i know live streams on youtube
are kind of rare right
capper demon cap redeeming capper demon
how do i get their cap or demon cap or
demon
i can
go
just twitch
i only watch you baby oh thank you
thank you
[Music]
i was spamming your vids and saw you
were alive that's good
capra's in the basement that's right
that's right okay okay i was trying to
remember how to get to the basement i
really like twitch i
really don't like twitch as well
i am not a fan of that platform at all
i kind of only watch
youtube now
i would say
i'm sorry l slat are we not paying
attention to you
[Music]
is metal not paying attention to you
[Music]
i saw your stream last night and decided
to watch it in the morning see i like
that about youtube where i feel like
like let's say you did miss the live
stream it's really not that big of a
deal to go back and watch it whereas on
twitch i don't feel like anybody goes
and watches vods right
i could be wrong about that but i know i
never did
i don't know why i'm killing these
people
okay let's pop this
i feel like i should kindle this as well
can you stream on reddit
and don't we remember that reddit does
not like me very much
i came for the elden ring streams and
vids you got me through elden ring
sweet
because if you guys are like me like
whenever i'm not streaming or like maybe
i'm editing or doing whatever like even
if i'm playing like a different game off
stream
i have on my other monitor or somewhere
in the room like a live stream or a
video going on
i definitely think a lot of people do
that
it's so hard to grow on twitch dude no
kidding it is ridiculously hard to grow
on twitch
i had
okay so think of this guys think of this
i had
how many followers do i have on tick
tock actually i haven't posted on tick
tock in over a month
i have 230 almost 234 000 followers on
tick tock right
234 000 that's a lot maybe not for tick
tock but whatever
and ev almost every single one of those
i plugged my twitch channel
and it took me
four years to get 20 000 followers on
twitch
and i had 25 million views
on tick tock which equated to 20 000
20 000 people
and in the last two months i've gotten
73 000 subscribers
otherwise known as followers on youtube
just just from making content on youtube
crazy
twitches twitch is ridiculous
uh in in terms of like difficulty to
grow
[Music]
get own dog
this is bad
yeah you quite literally do need other
platforms to grow on twitch 100
you can't just grow naturally on twitch
you can't
not possible
if i get out of this i'm the best
and i want that to be known by everybody
yeah do your cartwheel
i'm literally gonna die to a version of
maddie okay there we go
[Music]
i discovered your channel because of
fake news you posted about gideon off
near being there yeah fake news okay
buddy
okay
fake
news that you're doing well better on
youtube than in other platforms a
haunted like you mean like financially
yeah like way better
much much much much better
that's a turtle no that's only an elden
ring
why do you call me that because that's
your name
i like calling you by your name
dogs and rats dude
i do wish youtube did a better job of
letting you know when a creator is live
streaming yeah they're still kind of
figuring out their live streaming
aspects
i i would say it's pretty good like
i'm streaming in uh
1440p right now like that's big
hopefully the stream looks good
yeah i'm sure you guys aren't getting
ads every 10 seconds
i hope
and if you do you can skip them
oh my god
[Music]
well now i do metal now i do
yeah this is the remake or the remaster
donos are kind of slow
donors are slow everywhere nobody really
donates anymore
it's not i don't really care about that
okay is there a bonfire that is closer
to here because that took forever to get
here and i don't want to run through
this area again
can i go over here
i got an ad at the beginning but that's
it though
no
oh god
oh god
bears fair you do call me jacob
no bonfire is close by okay
nope unlike twitch yep
i swear
you're here i'm gonna ask this like if
you guys have been on twitch or watch
content on twitch
if you're like me press one
if there's a [ __ ] ad that plays on a
live stream i leave the
website right i at least leave the
stream
immediately when i see one
because it's like five minutes of ads
i'm gone
off the website or at least off of that
stream
just immediately yeah i would assume
most people do that they need to i think
youtube does ads really really well dude
like it can play but you can also skip
it in like five seconds most of the time
you know
i'm doing the thing
that didn't work
this is going well
what the [ __ ] was that
[Music]
that was awful
you like ads are you okay
hey if you like ads you like ads that's
fine
oh
yes
daddy what
loots boots shoe ad comes up immediately
after
that boss fight is a literal nightmare
it really is
enclosed space
dogs
look at the lead up to this boss fight
too
wow
what the [ __ ] do i do about that
[Music]
don't you dare go hollow
at least it wasn't fall damage
owned
i faked them
okay hopefully we don't just get
horrible rng
did i just get
what
what just happened
[Music]
i spoke that entire thing into existence
that is true i that's what happened
go through the shortcut
y'all told me there wasn't anything
closer
excellent
i'm having fun
[Music]
what's past the capper demon
anything
you know what i'm just gonna keep at it
i'm now a part of this
no you don't have to kill the capper
demon to go to the dragon do you
i don't think so
[Music]
i gotta calm down
it's starting to hurt my feelings
how hard i'm getting
just annihilated
i do want to complain real quick that
the dogs in this game are insane
i want to take him with me
[Applause]
what shortcut because y'all said there
wasn't any
there wasn't a shortcut
ah
[Applause]
i'm scared
come on
that's fine
move it
the real shortcut is death
is this even possible
what the [ __ ]
is this
okay i killed both dogs that's a plus
there's a [ __ ] tree in the way
dude this is scary
[Music]
no i love looking at trees while i'm
fighting a boss
this is great
terrible
holy [ __ ] give me a second people
oh my god
that was the worst boss i think i've
ever experienced in my life
that was terrible
okay what is this
demon great machete
no i already have the best best weapon
in the game we're good
all right we did
it think they're trolling about it okay
you know i gotta i gotta remember that i
actually have a chat now
and you guys just could be lying to me
right
you could be lying to me
and uh i need to accept that
you could just be pulling my chain brute
and that's fine
a large soul
did we lie about the latter
[Music]
no you didn't
what's over here
what is this talk
oh what the [ __ ]
why would i do that
what the [ __ ]
do i need anything here
you people we have water moss moisture
these nice iron bars i like it here i
really do
nothing good ever happened to me in life
but now that i'm undead i've never been
happier
she is bat [ __ ]
okay
oh this is the best design game of all
time
it just is
are we back at firelink oh my god
yep the design of this game is just the
best
[Applause]
even rick likes it
you tell by his moaning
you know i have to kill you because
you're just gonna [ __ ] follow me
all right i don't wanna die
that lady was weird
[Music]
dude come on bro just go back home
you did
okay
did you kindle firelink i think it's
already automatically kindled right
can i kindle this
oh what happens if i do that
if i kindle firelink
oh i actually have souls i can use too
hey
it's auto kindled
can i kindle while hollow oh [ __ ]
okay let me unhollow
[Music]
you need the right of kindling
okay i just won't do it y'all freaking
out
okay uh should i go
down like where where it was over there
the like where i was
i don't know how to say it to the sewers
should i go to the
[Music]
sewers gotta head back to work
hope the game goes well just wanted to
say keep up the good work
love the content and i love your
attitude
smiley face
can we get some smiles in the chat
thanks nathan
i appreciate that man
have a great time at work
excellent
excellent
smile
that is a long run dog
[Music]
the undead big
smile
okay
hopefully i'm going where you guys
want buy a repair box
is my weapon damaged at all
where am i right now wait a minute
can't go any deeper
oh
[Music]
the door's right there am i am i
tripping
oh it's right here okay yeah i'm
tripping balls
my bad
ignore me
do i have any pulleys
because i just get knocked over no
matter what
i don't like this area already
oh i'm just not a fan of whatever the
[ __ ] that was
i think i'm dead i'm dead
[Applause]
talk about a panic
attack
what are you hiding over here for
shut up
your mouth
okay
um
what the [ __ ]
this is terrifying
i don't know if i can stagger you so i'm
scared
i
i'm just so confused as to what just
happened
high frames
hey
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
be careful here okay i'll do my best sir
just know i love you all
yes
please you must help me
what is stopping me from throwing a bomb
at all these
dude
there you are
you must help me
or else
she'll have me for lunch
you're my only hope
oh please
what do i do
oh
there you are you must have or she'll
have me you're my only one
here buddy
thank you
i hold a bigger supple without you
being alive i started to think
thank you
thank you dearly
i am luencius
or the
this guy seems chill i like that guy
what can i get from you though
oh hello there i'm fine thanks to you
okay that's it all right bye
oh hello there we just talked i'm fine
thanks to you
goodbye
sweet dreams
sweet dreams are made of these
the first golf channel vid should be
what's in the bag
it's actually a good idea
it's a door
okay okay
that's a good idea if anyone who doesn't
know i started a golf channel
okay
didn't expect this
please don't kill me
excellent
all right
well to anyone who didn't know lorenzo
oh god
that's just insane
wowzer
crockey mate
didn't know i fell what the [ __ ]
does not open from this side i can't
even hear myself right now
oh god
i missed a bonfire
okay going back
oh god
this place is probably very stinky
or am i missing a bonfire here
oh i thought you were dead
there we go
oh right here
yo let's go thank you guys
thank you
oh this is super helpful let me pop some
of my uh
my sully voice
thank you kindly
we're doing so good
actually making a lot of progress today
i'm thinking three hour streams a day
what do you guys think
i think three hours is enough for me to
do everything else i want to do
throughout the day
and get a stream in each day
thoughts comments concerns
ooh should i kindle this i kind of want
to sounds good all right
see i can still work on videos
throughout the day as well
it's not long enough to take up up my
entire day as well
and i was thinking same time every day
too
same time
because three hours like
to be honest
are you guys really gonna watch like an
entirety of an eight hour stream
probably not
it's like three hours is fine
hopefully
dead rat
dead alright
this place must smell so bad dude
sewer chamber key
nice
okay that's an option
beware of invasion
what is this
oh this is the boss
right
these are big rats
oh god
i'm startled
what is that dance sir
you're welcome
i'm close to the boss
well that was just not fair
have you heard of eldon ring discovery
in which halma battle mages have their
name deprived from the ancient greek
word ima which means blood massacre or
kingship i have not heard of that it's
pretty cool though
whoa
that's pretty neato burrito
these guys have got to be weak to fire
huh
no this isn't my first playthrough i
haven't played it in three
three or more years though
i regret my decision to do that
oh god
oh i do have fire bombs
you're right
it's all unraveling voice
everything's going to [ __ ]
all right where's kirk
kirk
i just saw him where'd he go
oh god
where is he going
what what is he doing
no i've never played those
esther guy looks like he could parry my
butthole if he wanted to
i made that risky as am
let's go
okay
where the heck am i right now
is that blighttown
hello
who are you
not the voice i expected
i adore trinkets and oddities so i trade
for them
okay
bottomless box box allowing inventory
management at bonfires
whoa
i can get us his clothes
kill merchant
i'm not i don't wanna
you get the key for blighttown from
killing this area's boss
well that
no not to is
come back again i'm always available not
every trade was meant to be there'll be
more in store for us someday sometime
okay i like that guy
someone said there's a shortcut
i can't open the door
it doesn't open
are you talking about a different door
that rat wanted to die
um as fast as the boss
i mean i can't open the door though
oh he sells boss
armors that's really cool
okay
boss to your left
yep this feels like a boss no cappy on a
stack he's really squiddy
it's in the corner
like this
oh yo it's solaire okay okay we need to
do that we need to do that yeah yeah
okay that's the entrance
i'll go back since you're telling me to
i'm sorry for not understanding your
directions
i'll do better i swear
it's solaire praise the [ __ ]
sun boy
you'll praise the sun
i just want to say you can't just say
wrong way and expect me to know what
you're talking about all right
okay
so i don't even know where i'm at right
now
i forgot
hey yo wrong way
hey yo go back
back to merchant
i'm trying
i don't know where i am
oh my god
why can i only go down
am i tripping
hey yo merchant
did i fall down i literally don't
remember how i got down here
the camera clips into the pillars a lot
and it
i don't like it
solaire help
left from stairs
dog
stairs left
those are more stairs
boss room
going left
nope
is this really triggering
even more stairs
went right i went left
i'm trying to go into the merchant area
i don't know how to get there okay there
we go
okay
where's the shortcut y'all are talking
about far left corner this is probably
it
got it i know where i am now
thank you people
understood
okay let's use that
um
let's keep leveling strength why not
level 28 like a badass we are level 28.
nice
finally
shut your mouth
you stupid head
this stream is aggravating
you know what's crazy is you don't have
to watch is that nuts you could like
leave
if you don't like it
that crazy
is that just an insane concept
and it's gone
i find the chaos enjoyable
all right solaire let's do this thing
never would have thought of that
oh his entrance is just
bomb let's go buddy
is this boss hard
it's just a little alligator
oh
never mind
hold up genzo
never mind
how do you fight this thing
i can't lock on dude
[Music]
nice
does it have a tail attack
why can't i lock on there we go
okay
i understand that's an attack now
cut the tail off
[Applause]
it's not coming off yet
how
my butt
i don't want that right now
i feel like solaire's not doing anything
oh [ __ ]
you weren't kidding
should i be hitting its face
nice one slayer
[Applause]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa chill chill dog
yeah i feel like the face is not the
play
uh-oh
i think solaire is dead guys
you like that dodge okay slayer is dead
or boy
now
that's cringe
key okay
nice
25 000 dang
okay sick
good stuff boys good stuff
that was easy right guys
i don't go nowhere
now go back to merchant
okay god i'll just do whatever you say
god
pull up decks
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i will
was there a rat here bro
how do you know what to to hand like
what can lead to handing something
uh do you have new stuff
you can buy his face now it's kind of
cool well that is ashamed hi sir
check the new weapon dude we have the
black hallberg
i don't need to check any other weapon
we basically beat the game
[Music]
jtm
don't tell me what to do please thank
you
you're annoying
[Music]
okay
please check it okay
stop telling me what to do people
it was this one
wait 380
this acts one of the rare dragon weapons
is forming the tail of the gaping dragon
a distant deformed descendant of the
everlasting jargon
okay
go to the door just go to the door right
let's go to the door
how about you hold
the door of these nuts
okay
how about that
we can two hand
ooh kinda why does he swing it like that
is it too heavy
[Music]
why is he swinging it weird
okay let's see how good it is
not strong i've been told by quite
literally everyone that this is the best
weapon in the game
i think they're right
okay now i'll go to the door
bunch of freaks
take some armor off
i just upgraded
that's better
and he still swings like that okay
a light town
okay
what the [ __ ]
um
it's kind of dramatic
it's fine
it's over there
it's way too dank
mommy
okay
guess i'll go down here
look guys i'm gonna hold b
wow he figured it out
okay
oh i already don't like this at all
hey you guys like the color gr oh no
bye
okay
we made it
is a big ass
let me stick something up it
yeah this weapon's really good like holy
[ __ ]
hi frames
damn dude
what
the heck are these things
yeah i haven't even upgraded this and
it's this good like wow
am i going the right way
see now that i'm asking you guys for
help i would appreciate the help
instead of just telling me what to do
i
[Music]
just
don't know
what that was
just happened
there is no right way in blighttown
understood
why does my character run so weird down
these stairs
that never happened
i don't know what you guys are talking
about
this place sucks in general can't give
too many directions
okay
we will power through it together right
guys
we're a team
full of
positivity and friendship right
i'm probably gonna end here in about
five minutes but we're gonna try and get
to some type of bonfire edge before i do
that
oh my god
how do you not fall off
excellent
no we have the best best weapon in the
game we're good
i feel like the falling aspect of
blighttown is the hardest part of it
what's your golf channel agt golf
here we go
we gotta we got our souls back excellent
excellent
i don't like this guy over here
[Applause]
now you're dead
stupid idiot
the locals are not happy with the
commotion you were causing i can see
that i can see that
you don't like that i'm just destroying
your stuff
too bad
i hate your stuff
man this just looks
awful i love it
can i jump over there let's not try
let's not attempt that
is he using a corpse
to hit me with
that's what i like to see
that's a hundred percent falling
what the
wow okay
that looks scary
you can't can i jump this
easily
let me practice a jump
if i die the stream ends
we got a little bit more of a connection
now boys
good stuff
hey
this is a perfect place to end the
stream
you guys like how high my voice can go
all right
uh 25 strengthy noodles which i think
was the requirement for this weapon yeah
that might have actually been 30 25 for
decks anyway we're gonna figure that out
tomorrow
for now we're gonna be done because we
have reached our three hour marker close
to it
i'm gonna wait till we hit the three
hour mark
but uh what else do i wanna tell you
guys about i started a golf channel that
i don't know how to record content for
yet but i'm gonna figure that out
eventually
um
so go check out agt golf
appreciate it
some stuff will go out there whenever i
figure out how to do it
too late that bonfire is hell to escape
that's okay
we're gonna be fine
we'll get out of tomorrow i've been
thinking what time do i start today 10
a.m
cst
yes
yeah it's almost one so 10 a.m cst i'm
gonna try and do that i'm gonna try and
do this every day chat
um this isn't just for dark souls that i
want to do this stream series on i want
to do it for all of the games um
so
dark souls dark souls 2 dark souls 3
bloodborne i'm gonna try and get my
hands on a ps5 to play demon souls all
that stuff so you wanna be my cameraman
all right i appreciate that metal thank
you i'll be your cameraman too anyway i
appreciate you all being here make sure
to sub
go follow me on twitter please
trying to grow my twitter because
uh sponsors like twitter for some reason
um
join our discord please join the discord
everything's linked in the description
by the way but go join our discord
there's a lot of cool people talking
about dark souls and eldon ring and all
kinds of stuffs there so if you're
interested in that
go check out discord and appreciate it
but that was a really good stream
appreciate you guys being here i will be
back tomorrow so
have a great rest of your day
and
what else do i want to say
i will give joy some tummy rubs she gets
tummy rubs every day all day
and for every new sub she gets even more
tummy rubs
because she's awesome and we love her um
yeah that was a really good stream
appreciate y'all
trying to think if i
am forgetting anything
hmm i don't think so
so
i'm gonna call it there guys
have a great rest of your day love every
single one of you and i'll see you
tomorrow
peace and love
bye bye bye bye bye bye
oh you don't get any sound lol okay bye
guys